The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Today I'm
going to talk a little bit
about computer architecture.
And how computer architecture
impacts performance
engineering.
So the main part of this is
going through a long overview
of the Pentium, the Nahalem
architecture that in the
machines that you guys
are using, which
is hot off the press.
Six core processor that's
out there now.
And then I will talk a little
bit about profiling a program.
And then the next lecture, the
TAs are going to demonstrate
how to use some of those
profiling tools that you guys
are supposed to use for
the project two.
And I guess the project two will
probably appear, since we
had a delay, so probably
be up here 24 delayed.
We'll release the project,
too, up there.
And then at the end of the talk,
end of the lecture, I'm
going to talk about a little
bit of example.
Go to some program and show what
you can gain by looking
at things like profiling,
and what
information that you gain.
Just kind of do a
high level view.
So let's start something.
So how many of you have had
a chip in your hand.
Microprocessor in your hand.
Some.
There's some people
who haven't.
So I brought some show
and tell things.
So what I'm going to do
is pass them around.
And there are two things that
are actually very valuable
that I want to tell you and then
make sure that they don't
get damaged.
So this is a Pentium 3 that's
already in a big
heat sink in there.
So you can't see that much, but
they're really cute and
they created a hologram of the
chip and put it there so you
can catch, I guess, people who
are trying to use counterfeit
and stuff like that.
So this is MDK 6 with
the packaging.
I'm going to send it
around in there.
And this is a Pentium Pro.
Normally what happens is that
when the first dye comes out,
this is humongous,
giganiticized.
But after a couple of
generations, what you do is
you take the same circuit and
you shrink it and shrink it.
This is probably what
two shrinks--
so the actual dye right now is
very small because this is
copper [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
later process that things
have been shrunk.
This is a Core Two Duo
So I think there's a
two cores in there.
So I didn't want to bring
anything newer because those
chips are darn expensive, and
if you touch it, basically
just static will basically
destroy the process.
So these are something that
came out of things that
doesn't work.
The next two things.
These are--
I really need to get this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] because these
are like the only thing
that's the one
available in this world.
Basically there's only
one of item.
So at MIT, we build a process a
couple of years ago called a
row processor.
So here's a row dye before
it's being mounted.
So this is what comes out after
all the fabrication,
before it goes into this
mounting with all the pins.
If you look at the top of this
one, what do you see?
It's all these dots, which
are basically where
all the pins go.
So you don't actually even see
inside the dye in this one.
However, then you pay a bunch
of money to these people who
go and grind that chip.
You take a real working chip and
you grind it, and expose
insides of the chip.
So this is a ground chip that's
exposed the metal layering.
In fact, this you can see real
circuits in the chip.
So I don't think anybody has the
mission that's required to
see the transistors or
even the circuits.
But it's kind of interesting
to see.
So here are these two
things, so some show
and tell like that.
Ah-ha.
And this.
This is entire reason that
microprocessor not getting
faster anymore.
Because this is one humongo heap
thing that you put in the
modern machines, and there's a
huge fan that goes above that.
And you can't keep building
larger and larger heat things
to get the heat out.
And so that this why the heat
is paramount, and that's why
we can't run 4 gigahertz,
10 gigahertz process.
We are thick into the current
kind of gigahertz train, and
then we [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
multiple cores.
So it's a big, humongo block
in there, and then some
actually might even have
a bigger block.
So while this go around, let's
start the lecture.
So computer architecting
includes
many different things.
You are doing instructions,
memory, IEO Bus, disk systems,
GPU, graphics, all
of those things.
But we are not getting
into beyond
instruction and memory system.
So we are going to focus on
that, but if you really want
to understand the full end to
end performance, you have to
worry about all those
other things.
So that said, let's go into
instructions and memory.
So here is the Nehalem
processor.
And there's a beautiful
picture of the
processor in the left.
This as kind of the role
chip that I'm showing.
They have ground out the upper
layers and showed some of the
layers in there.
So that's what you get when
you buy the Nehalem.
And this very complicated
diagram in the right side,
it's an abstract notion of
what's happening inside.
So what you do is go a little
bit into this [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
diagram, and trying to
understand what impact it
would have on you.
This is not architecture class,
but you, as trying to
get performance, has to make
sure all these components
works pretty well.
That said, it's very hard to
understand in a modern
microprocessor exactly
what's going on.
Not even Intel understand
what's going
on most of the time.
And so a lot of things
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So you can't ask tell
me exactly what
happened or get there.
So you can be fussy.
On the other hand, being fussy
means there's a level of
abstraction that you
have to live with.
And what that means is when
something hit their head very
hard, and have a really bad
situation you can see that and
you can react to that.
But there are a lot of small
things that happen.
These things interact in
very complex ways.
So you don't understand exactly
the minor detail
what's going on in these
microprocessor for a given
application.
A lot of different things might
work different ways.
So that's it.
So if we look at what you learn
from 004, so what that
means is instruction.
You have here two
instructions.
One after the other.
So if the instructions
take [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
cycle.
So we see the
non-[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
method.
So you look at why it's probably
taking five cycles.
So that's because it's doing
different things.
You are doing instruction fetch,
instruction decode,
after that execute.
Then you do some memory
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] and then find
the right packet in there.
So you do all those things
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
instruction, and then
you start the next
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] cycle.
Of course, this is
very necessary.
So the first two people
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
After I do instruction fetch,
that logic that's doing
instruction fetch is not doing
anything for a while.
Why don't I start the next
instruction phase immediately
because you are doing the same
circuit, and then recycle,
that's so it can go do the next
thing, and next thing,
and next thing.
And by doing that, well I can
basically recycle, I can get
the instruction through
the system.
So this looks very nice and
simple and you can get.
So what are they
choosing here?
Is the world this
nice and simple?
No.
OK, what might happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: You have a
lot of issues that normally
cause hazards.
So there could be three
different type of hazard.
There's a thing called
structural hazard.
What you are trying to do is
attempt to use the same
hardware, do two things, but
there's only one hardware.
You can't get two things done.
One has to be after another.
And there's a thing called
data hazards.
That means you're trying to
run these things, one now
another, but in logically.
They have to run sequence
serially.
So that means that's a data
dependence, I'll get into,
that makes it impossible to make
these things run in the
pipeline fashion.
And finally, this control has
things like branches and
things like that,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
interfere with that.
So let me get a little
bit detail down here.
So the first thing we have is
what we call data hazard.
I will talk about two
different hazards.
So before I go there, I will
share a little bit about this
assembly representation.
In two lectures, you're going
to get a more deep drilling
into the how to go from
C to Assembly.
But before that, so what this
instruction says, this is the
normal x86 form.
We are doing add long.
Add in to the values in this
rbx and rax and put the
results back into rax.
So you are doing rbx plus rax
and get the result into rax.
You are subjecting rax
with rcx and put the
results into rcx.
So basically all the rest of
the results are in the
right-hand side.
Two [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
are basically the first
and second.
So the last one gets
read and modified.
So that's the way
it's weighted.
So while you have two is--
question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Instruction,
yeah.
It's different concept.
The second instruction is data
dependent, of course.
What's happening is I am writing
this value here, which
will be read by this guy here.
So I write something
and the next
instruction is reading that.
The problem is it's the right
thing must not be available
until very late in
the pipeline.
So they cannot execute
simultaneously and all that
thing basically of
this dependence.
This is called basically read
after write, because I'm going
to read after it's
been written.
And if you look at the pipeline
here, what happens is
the write happens here, and the
next feed has to happen
somewhere down here.
So until this one, this
slide [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
so this status has to get
delayed after this point.
This make sense?
Because I'm trying to in here
read something that's not
going to be produced for
two more clock cycles.
So that's not available
and I can't do that.
Make sense?
OK.
So this next cycle dependence
is called name dependence.
That's the dependence
and anti-dependence.
Basically what it's doing is two
instructions are using the
same register.
And because of that I can't
start to see the radius there
until the other one switches
off with the register.
So in here, what's happening
here is I am
subtracting rax and rbx.
I'm putting the value in rbx.
And here I am adding rcx to
rax, and basically start
putting the value in rax.
The problem here is I cannot
modify rax before this guy has
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the value in here.
So that means I'm trying to go
modify it, and say no, no, no.
You can't touch it because
somebody will still want to
get the value, and I can't
go destroy the value.
And I had to [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
That's the first type of what
you call anti-dependence.
And because of this, you
both are using rax.
There's no real data movement,
but it basically
has the same space.
I had to wait till the other
person can be evicted before I
can read that register.
So these are called write
after read hazard.
The other type of dependence is
called output dependence.
So I am updating rax twice, and
of course in this simple
example we can probably even
drop this instruction because
it doesn't matter because
I'm re-writing it.
But if there's something in
between also reading, what
happens is I can't do
this in wrong order.
The last value that updated has
to be this instruction.
So we had to make sure this
instruction happens after this
instruction.
So we have a dependence, so
there's some ordering in here
that has to be maintained.
And this is call write
after write hazard.
So instructions that have medium
dependence, we can
actually get rid of the
dependent by what we call
register renaming.
So everybody uses rax, so that's
kind of artifact of
good old inter [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
architecture sometimes
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
when register, so you have to
use the same register for
many, many things.
So in a modern--
inside the hardware
there's what we
call a register renaming.
You have lots more slots for the
same registers, and even
when you're using rax, this is
an old one, this is a new one,
use a different location
for the new one.
So I can do renaming.
And then basically hardware
can get rid of that.
The next interesting thing
is control hazard.
So here what we see, if you had
this kind of a loop, s1,
it's control dependent on p1.
So we can't do s1 until
p1 is done.
Or s2 until p2 is done.
So we are [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the p1 condition is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
before you can do s1 and
for the next one.
So the interesting thing is
control dependence also we can
get rid of it by doing
speculation.
So the idea there what hardware
does is it will say
wait a minute.
I know I have to wait till p1 is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] to do s1.
But I'm going to do s1 anyway.
I will just go to s1,
speculatively.
And then at the end of doing
that, at some time when p1 is
calculated, and I know
what the p1, I
said did I do it right?
If I did it right, I'm good.
If I did something wrong,
I have done some
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that is not useful for that.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So what
happens is there's this thing
called a write buffer.
The complex thing is at the
end of the day, the
instructions have to
be get committed in
the order they arrive.
So before committing, you keep
the state in buffers without
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
into the main one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So right
back into memory doesn't
happen until the commit point.
But when you read something,
before reading the memory, say
OK, I have updated something,
is it in the right buffer?
So I read things from the
right buffer in there.
So you had to go in
order commitment.
Because you can't do out of
order commitment, that can do
crazy things.
You do in order commitment, but
inside the metrics things
can go easier.
I'm just kind of jumping
the gun a little bit.
So in a modern Nehalem
processor, these are kind of
Intel [UNINTELLIGIBLE], so you
don't know exactly what it is.
In some place it says it
has 16 clock cycles.
So it says it might be 16
stages of pipeline.
And another place it says 20
to 24 stages of pipeline.
OK, if you work for Intel and
sign the NDA you will get the
exact number.
But it doesn't matter.
It's a lot of pipeline
stages, so that's
all you need to know.
So what happens is if you are
doing this in sort of five
stage, like what you did
in probably beta.
You do instruction decode,
instruction queue, pre-record
queue, decode, register rename,
and allocate registers.
And then there's thing called
reservation and stations that
wait for when data's available
to execute that instruction.
And then execute, and then
basically go there.
This is what normally
instruction life would be, if
everything goes one after
another after another.
So what to get out of this is
the pipelines are long.
So pipeline stores and stuff
can be expensive.
So the other thing you can
do in abstract way
is do multiple issue.
So if you do pipeline, what
happens is you do one at a
time so you can use the pipeline
stages nicely.
How about instead of having one
unit, if you have integer
unit and a floating
point unit.
And every clock cycle you
can basically abstract.
You could say look, I'm taking
interger instruction, I'm
taking floating point
instruction, and take them
both together [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And then whala, at the end of
the day in one clock cycle I
can [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
two instructions, one integer,
one floating point, if you
have two different
sets in there.
So this is also very nice.
You can get a lot of what we
call super scaler performance.
However, it's called instruction
level parallelism.
There's a lot of problems, also
things that you worry.
Well first of all, you have to
have enough instruction in
level parallel.
Because the instruction you get
is the sequence history,
and you see one after another.
I mean you write your
program and compile.
It looks like you run one
instruction, finish it, run
another, run another.
So in order to form parallely,
you're to find things.
You can actually do parallel.
That takes time.
And of course, between hardware
and software you are
to maintain that preserve order
of instructions, because
you want to make sure that it
looks like and it feels like
you ran one after another
after another.
You don't want things to run in
a haphazard way and create
arbitrary result.
And so you have to, again,
things like this, data
dependences, control dependences
have to be
satisfied when you're getting
this parallelism.
So data dependency, there's a
hazard, and determining which
order you can run things.
So for example, output
dependence.
Say look, I can't just
run them parallel.
I have to make one after
another after another.
You're to get all those
things done.
And also if you're lot of
dependency kind of gives you
bounds, how much parallelism
you can get.
If things are all one dependent
against one after
another, you can't run
them parallel.
You have to wait to run
things to another one.
So by looking at data
dependence, as you can figure
out, OK look, did I get good
performance, good ILT or not?
So what we want to do is exploit
this parallelism like
we see in the program order.
And basically make sure that
you always get the
same result on that.
One way of getting parallelism
that is in modern process is
called multimedia instruction.
It's called SIMD in academic
circle, something like Single
Instruction Multiple Data, and
it's called data level
parallelism, and Intel, of
course, has to give the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] name
they call SSE, they
just call it MMX.
So the idea there is
look, they are
building this wide measure.
They can easily build 128
bit wide register.
But you most probably don't
need 128 bit data, because
that's too big.
But they can build this large.
And most will tell you about
happy with about 32 bit data.
So what?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
wait a minute.
You build this wide thing.
But you can chop it into four
pieces or eight pieces or two
pieces, what you want.
So here we chop that large
thing into four pieces.
And then what you can do is in
a single instruction, you can
instead of doing one large add,
the same type of adder,
you can add four separate
things.
Four small parts.
So you're assuring add, but
instead of adding 228 bit
data, what you are doing is
adding here, four 32 bit data.
The entire architecture
looks very identical
to an 228 bit data.
It's basically to remember
your double
004, it's like a carry.
Then just have to
come the carry.
You don't carry from here
to here, and do that.
So this is you're loading this
large chunk, and you are just
working on these things.
And whala, by doing that,
having the same kind of
circuitry, you get much
better parallelism.
And if you have like 8 bit data,
boy, you can get lots of
parallelism.
So there's all these multiple
instructions in there.
And so what you can do is you
can have a loop like this.
So you can, in every situation,
you can add the I
to BI, and create pretty
good [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So you can do one at a time.
But assume you have
32 bit values.
Instead of doing-- single
instruction you can load 0 to
8 3 in one go.
B0 to BC in one go.
Just do the add of all four in
one, go [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So in single time you get
four things done.
So this is really cool.
And if you remember my first
lecture, we showed this matrix
multiplier.
If you get [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in there, you get a lot less
instructions executed.
We got a nice [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So I'm going down, so the top
path I'm showing, the C code--
for that loop, and then the
bottom half in there, I'm
showing the normal
assembly that we
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], what you see.
And once you start understanding
assembly a
little bit more, you can go
ahead and read this and see
what's going on.
And then if you
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], you get a
humongous beast like this.
This has unrolled
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], whatever.
And this is the kind of code
that we generated by
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And that's just much,
much faster than
the one on the left.
Any questions so far?
OK.
So when we have this superscalar
[UNINTELLIGIBLE],
with multiple execution, so what
you can do is in a clock
cycle, you can do
a lot of things.
So in the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
processor, you have basically
six things, six execution things
that can happen in one
clock cycle.
It's not the same thing, so
you can do a data store.
You can store address, load
address from there, and then
you can do three different
type of executions.
There are three units in here.
In here you can do either
integer or SSE, add or move
instruction, this unit can do
this kind of instruction, you
can have a floating point
add-in around here.
This one needs to also have this
bunch of different things
you can do.
So this complex hardware, we'll
kind of figure out, OK,
if you have these instructions,
figure out what
of these [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
are available.
If the instruction is able to
execute, it will put it into
one of these and het
the results out.
So if you're lucky, what you
can see is, you might get
about six instructions
going each cycle.
So if you look at the mesh
here, what we call clock
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] instruction,
it could be 1/6.
If you're lucky.
If you can run the mesh into
the metal, that means
everything is working
all the time.
It's very hard to find that
kind of program, but
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
can get something like that.
That's really cool.
So what happens is to get this
thing, they do things called
out-of-order instruction.
So what that means is, issuing
this varying number of
instructions in the clock,
in here, in the Nehalem
processor, you can store 128
instructions in this core
instruction buffer.
[INAUDIBLE]
better name than instruction
buffer.
If you can see that, [INAUDIBLE]
very far.
But [INAUDIBLE] up
there, sorry.
Here.
It's called reservation
stations.
So when you put it in, all
those [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
reformation [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
ready to get, and the minute
it becomes available, that means
all the data is ready
for it to run, you can basically
issue that and run.
So what they're doing is,
in these hundreds of
instructions, you're figuring
out the patterns you can run.
And a minute some part is
available, the data becomes
available, you can run that.
And so that means the program
might have instructions in
certain order.
It gets executed in very
different orders than what the
program has.
So that's what call you
can give things like
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
register, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
dependencies, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
execution.
And sometimes you might
run speculator.
You might not know.
You might have the data, but
there might be controlled
dependence.
You might not know that it's
actually is supposed to
happen, but it says
wait a minute, I
have execution available.
It's not doing anything.
OK, let's run it and keep the
results, and if it is actually
useful, we'll use it.
Otherwise, we'll
throw it away.
You can do things like that.
And that's a speculation.
So another type of
speculation--
speculation mostly means, you
want to do something, but you
don't know whether
you can do it.
So how do you go about
doing that?
The way that interprocess and
modern processor do, is they
do a lot of predictions.
It has like this is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] say, look at
the crystal ball and say,
aha, this is the future.
And it does that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
really many things.
So it does things like branch
prediction, value prediction,
prefetching.
So it says, aha, I don't know
where you're going, but I
think you are going home
after the class.
And then probably if I said
something like this, it's
probably right for most
of the people.
And actually, no, in this class,
most of you, again,
will probably go to sleep after
the class, because of
the project.
So if I do that probably I do
a very good prediction.
How many of you are going to go
to sleep after the class?
Huh, my prediction
is not that good.
OK.
We'll see.
So you can go all these kinds
of things, identify normal
behavior programs to
deal with that.
Ad what prefetching says is,
if I look at what you have
been taking from the money,
there are some patterns, and
I'm expecting you to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that pattern, and I will
basically get the data, even
though you don't ask for it,
because I'm expecting you to
be doing that.
It's like a very good butler who
can really think, you ask
something, have that ready
for you, basically.
So by doing that, you can get
much better parallelism,
because now you're not waiting
for that to be sure
that you can do it.
You're just kind of doing this,
assuming you might be
using it, and if you do it
really well, you're actually
going to use it.
And that will be useful.
So for example, even things
like value prediction.
Value prediction says,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to get out, you know when you
do this complex calculation,
most of the time,
data is zero.
You multiply and add a lot of
zeroes, and if you're doing
spreadsheets, all it is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] calculations.
So if I don't know the value,
let me assume it's 0.
And that actually works
most of the time.
Or you look at the last couple
of times, what has happened to
that [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
and there,
let me predict something.
And people to find these kind
of things that are a lot of
patterns in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
program.
And if it works, that's
really great.
So in speculation, what you do
is first issue and execute.
As if the branch was--
I already knew where it is
going, just by using the
prediction.
And if I just know dynamic
scheduling, I am only doing
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
issues, I am not going to
execute until I know
everything is [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So it's speculation goes
one step beyond.
It's what we call a data
flow execution
model, the dynamic schedule.
And that means, the minute the
data is ready and everything
is ready, you can execute, even
though it might not mean
the same mode of the program.
It might be much later
instruction.
But implicitly, you
can execute that.
So again, the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
pipeline, you can do
20 to 24 stage or
16, whatever is correct.
The other thing it does is
this crazy thing called
micro-ops that puts everybody
out to a loop.
So what happened was-- this
is kind of historical--
Intel, a long time ago, came up
with the x86 architecture.
They came up with this
instruction set.
That instruction set is called
a CISC instruction set.
It's a complex instruction
set architecture.
What that means is there are
these instructions there are
that are really,
really complex.
You can move an entire string
from one place to another in
one instruction.
The problem is, most
instructions cannot
be done in one cycle.
So what modern [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
did was, they built a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] compiler into
the hardware.
So what happens inside this
process is, take this CISC
instruction and compile them
down to these particular
micro-operations, that each
operation is small can be done
in basically one cycle.
So it's doing this
mapping in there.
And then inside the computer,
it's basically
dealing with micro-ops.
So up to here, it's dealing with
these long instructions,
and here it's precoding and
decoding into micro-ops.
So after that, so what that
means, every cycle, it can
issue 6 micro-ops.
So there might be 6 instructions
you know, 3, or
even 1, depending on how many
micro-ops [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So if you look at instruction
manual in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], you can
see how many micro-op
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] instruction
it's going into, and if it's
large, that means those
instructions are slow.
And you can have this 120
micro-op waiting to be
executed, sitting in this
reservation station.
Basically, they are
waiting there.
The minute the data is
available, and then a slot
available, it will go down, get
executed, and come back.
So branch prediction,
basically--
the problem with branches is
if you have this very nice
pipeline, what happens is,
branch target is not known
until this target
detection time.
Where is my mouse?
OK.
Until this point, I don't know
whether the branch, where I am
supposed to go.
And so how do I go ahead and get
the instruction, because I
don't know where I'm going
until this point.
Even worse, I might not
even know address.
Some [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you are going AOB, you are
taken or not taken.
But sometimes there might
be [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
branches.
I don't even, if I'm returning
the return
address in the stack.
Until I go fit the stack and
load it and all those things,
I don't know where I'm
going, so I had to
wait until this point.
So if I do it, basically
I have to
wait until this pipeline.
All these things are
going to stalled.
Nothing happens in here.
This is first stage.
You can have a interested
pipeline.
You are waiting 20 stages, just
stalled, doing nothing.
And then there's superscalar
plus 20.
So that means 20 cycles without
the [? 6 issues ?]
you can do.
So 6 plus 20 is 120 possible
instructions wasted, and it's
a lot of waste.
So you don't want to do that.
So what you do is, you build a
predictor to figure out which
direction the brand is going.
And depending on what the
predictor do, and the neat
thing is, these days, these
predictions are
really, really good.
They can predict up to 99 points
plus [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
where you're going.
So it's like me telling you,
you guys are all going to
sleep afterwards, and this
is going to sleep on me.
So what you can predict,
I will say, aha!
I tell you, you are going
in that direction.
This is like going to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I think you're going
that direction, and
then you just go there.
And 99% of the time, you're OK,
and when [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
finally decided, you can say,
oh, that was slight.
If you're wrong, you squash
everything and restart.
And so modern predictors are
this very complicated beast.
It looks at things like what
happened previously.
It looks at [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
call stack where are the call
stack, what went into
the call stack.
And then when you're returning,
you can predict
where we might be returning.
A lot of different things go in
there, and in fact, we see
the core microarchitecture that
came before Nehalem's
predictor, and Nehalem
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], oh, it even
has more things, and so it's
even more different.
So these guys are doing
these complex things.
What that means is, sometimes
it affects program in a way
that you think, oh, huh, this is
something that I don't know
what might happen.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
this condition, I might not
know what might happen.
But model prediction sometimes
surprises you.
Aha, I know there's a pattern,
I recognize that pattern, and
I go about that.
And every architecture, I try
different kinds of patterns,
and I find the architectures
get better and better.
So for example, at some point,
if you go odd-even, odd-even
branches, if you assume I have
a loop, I say, if i is odd,
going one direction,
otherwise not.
Pentium 3 type thing, OK.
It just screw up
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
with every time it's doing
something different.
I don't know what's going on.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Pentium I'd probably say aha,
there's a pattern, odd-even,
odd-even, it figure out.
I core 2 figures out things like
every third, every fourth
type pattern it figures out.
And then things get
better and better.
There's very complicated
patterns you do, these guys
manage to figure out.
Which is kind of fun, to
see what it can figure
out, what it can't.
By writing a very small program,
you can get that.
I show some of that.
So the next thing that you have
to worry about is the
memory system.
So the memory system, if you
want to be the computer, what
you want to do is have a
lot of very fast memory
very close to you.
You can do that.
It's going to be
very expensive.
Sometimes through SQL you
can't even attain that,
because by the time you build a
lot of things, it's actually
already far away from
you, because we are
running very fast here.
So the way you deal with that
is building caches.
That means you keep a small
amount of things close to you
in there, and you put things
in that cache in a way that
hopefully, those are
the things you
will be using anyways.
So it works very nicely.
So the reason that can be done
is in programming, when you
run a program, there are two
types of behaviors that it
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] to
take advantage of.
One thing is called
temporal locality.
What that means is, most
programs, if you use you some
data, there's a good chance you
are going to use the same
data very soon.
Because normally, there's a
thing called a working set.
I am working with a certain
set of data.
I'm basically touching these
things again and again.
So if I use that, I'm going
to use that data again.
So that means I want to keep the
data that I used close by.
Other one is called
special locality.
That means, if I use some
data, I have a very good
chance that I might be using
a neighboring data item.
Because if I am accessing a
structure or an array, if I'm
accessing something, I
might be accessing a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] neighbor
thing next.
So there's what's called
partial locality.
And taking advantage of these
two, you can build this very
fast memory system that feels
like you have a huge amount of
memory very close to you.
Of course, the opposite
is true.
If your program doesn't behave
like that, it looks like you
have lots of memory very far
from you, and the program
becomes very, very slow.
Because memories didn't speed
up as fast as processors.
So what that means is, every
generation, the memory
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] further and
further away, slower and
slower and slower.
And this is how we manage
to keep the
machines running fast.
So if you look at what's going
on every level, I just gave
you a diagram.
I won't go through detail.
You can look at it later.
There are caches, and higher
levels you can
only keep very small.
And one like [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
you can only keep a couple of
hundred bytes in
the registers.
But very fast exercise.
Then you go to cache.
I see on-chip stuff.
We can keep a little bit more,
access time go down, and then
finally when you go to main
memory, you can keep a huge
amount, slow access.
And even at the end, something
like tape, you can keep a huge
amount of stuff.
Almost infinite amount
of stuff.
But it takes hours to get
the tape access is not
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So there's this hierarchy, and
there are a certain amount
things you want.
You are using [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
very fast.
You don't want to
put it in tape.
But you know something that you
might access in a year,
that's probably a good
place to put it.
So there's this hierarchy
there.
And then you have cache, what
happens is, you want to give
the illusion everything is
there, but when you go to
access it, the data might
not be there.
There are many reasons it might
not be there, so let's
go through some of
the reasons.
So one thing is called
cold miss.
That means it's the first time
I've seen that data.
So it cannot be in the cache.
If it's the first time I was
asking the disk, it's probably
sitting very back in main
memory, or somewhere in the
disk, and I have to go get it.
One way to get around this
problem is prefetching.
So if I keep accessing
this I say, aha.
You're accessing this
in this pattern.
And there's a good probability
the next pattern is here, and
OK, go get it very fast, because
you're coming in that
sort of direction.
So by doing prefetching, you
might be able to get rid of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] is happening.
Then there's a thing called
capacity miss.
What that means is, you're
accessing a lot of data.
At some point, you have
accessed enough data,
everything you accessed cannot
be fit in the cache, and you
have to throw out some of the
data to put the next one.
So most caches use the
a policy called
least recently used.
That means the data that you
unpacked for the longest time
gets thrown out of the cache.
But the problem is, at some
point, you're going to come
back to it.
And if you come back to it after
a long time, that thing
has been out of that
level of cache.
This happened at every level.
So what that means is, you have
a thing called a working
set, that you keep working
again and using.
If the working set is a little
bit larger than the cache,
when you come back to that,
the data is gone.
It's not in the cache.
So you want to kind of create a
working set that fits in the
cache nicely, at ever
level, basically.
You can do something like
pre-fetching and gets around
it, but if you can avoid
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], that's
really nice.
Then there's a thing called
a conflict miss.
One way of cache work-- it
doesn't let you store
everything in every location.
Sometimes there are some
locations in cache
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
associated with it.
Did you get [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
associated in 004??
Associativity?
OK.
Again, I will talk about cache
associated [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
but I'm going to talk about
memory system later and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] there.
And what that means is, this
is a really bad behavior,
because you are only accessing
a small amount of things, but
all of the data, all
the aggregate can't
fit into the cache.
The pattern makes it only fit
into a small part of the
cache, so you had to
throw the data out.
I'll get back to this.
I'm just going to
put it there.
And then in a multiprocess
system, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
multicourse, there's a thing
called true sharing.
That means I [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
data [UNINTELLIGIBLE], and the
next time [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
want to trust the data.
So I have to give the data to
you, so you're getting cache.
And then when I want to use my
data, it's [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I have to get it back to me.
So I'm kind of using data back
and forth, back and forth.
So that's called true sharing.
And a more hideous form of that
is called false sharing.
That means most of the data
is in a cache line.
When you move data you
move the cache line.
So what I'm doing, is I'm using
my data myself, and you
are using some other data, but
unfortunately, they're in the
same cache line.
So when I say, OK, I want my
data, I get the entire cache
line, including your
data, and then you
want to use your data.
You say, oops, it's
not with me.
And I then that means
you [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
go to you, and at that
point, I don't have
my data in my cache.
So this data is going
back and forth.
Even though I never touch your
data, we have two separate
data, but it's going back.
I will get this things in a
lot more detail in later
lectures, so this is kind
of giving [INAUDIBLE].
So there are all of these
different ways that the data
can be not in the cache.
So here is what the
processor you are
working with looks like.
There are 6 cores, and there
are L1 separate instruction
and data caches, and then
there's L2 unified cache,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
L3 cache or [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
and then there's main memory.
So it's even this deep,
deep, deep cache
hierarchy going on then.
And then right-hand side, I kind
of showed the difference.
And the interesting thing to
realize is, the L1 cache
delays about 4 nanoseconds.
It gets a little bit, 2 1/2
times slower when you go to L2
cache, and [? 12 ?] times
slower when you go to L3
cache, and even more slow when
you go to main memory.
So every time you go down,
it gets slower
and slower and slower.
That's basically the
gist of it in here.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Each core has two L1
cache for instructions and
[INAUDIBLE]?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: And
instruction data.
So instruction goes
one direction,
data goes in one direction.
So next I want to talk a little
bit about profiling.
So predictor who is
going to be--
the first part of the predictor
is all about profiling.
Profiling is very important,
because you run a program.
It doesn't do well.
So how do you know
what's going on?
First of all, you do know, even
if it's not doing well.
And if it's not doing well,
what's the reason?
So just having one number,
that then saying it's
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] in 10 minutes,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
5 minutes, doesn't tell
you too much.
You know what to look if you
have a large program.
The profiling means going,
looking at what the program is
doing to get an understanding
in there.
So what you want to do was
collect this performance data
while running the application,
and then if you're a large
application, you want to
organize and display data in
that a variety of ways, and a
lot of times, relate that data
to source code, and see
what that means in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
code.
And hopefully by looking at this
one, you can identify,
ha, there's a problem here.
So there are a bunch of tools.
Intel Vtune, gprof,
oprofile, perf.
So you guys are going to use
mainly perf, and we will
probably talk a little
bit about gprof.
And next time when you come,
next lecture we'll talk about
this a lot more.
So profiling is mainly to find
where in an application or a
system there is a significant
amount of activity.
And when the significant amount
of activity you want to
know whether those activity can
be avoided, or there's a
problem here.
So there are some
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
significant to what's there,
it could be anywhere.
It might be addressed
in the memory,
something might be happening.
It might be in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
system, some kind of process in
the operating system might
be happening in one thread, it
might be happening in an
executable file or a module.
If you know the symbol of
something, you can say, oh,
huh, that mode, that actually
is this function, and if you
know even more information about
the program, you can
say, aha, that's false,
and in fact it's
this line of the program.
So you get this information from
the application when you
compile that you can say debug
information, say aha, this
happens in this line
of the program
that's having this problem.
So you can break it down and
get that info like that.
[PHONE RINGING]
Somebody's trying to call me.
Hold on.
OK.
Secondly, we care about
significant activity.
If the activity just happened
only a few times, happened
only nanoseconds of execution
time, who cares?
You don't want to do that.
You want to focus on
things that matter.
And the key thing about
this [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
If you spend most of your time
in insignificant things, you
would get insignificant
performance improvement.
If you found the significant
part and work on that, you can
get significant gains.
So the key thing is to find
the significant ones.
[PHONE RINGING]
Excuse me.
OK.
And the final activity.
So activity means time is spent
in doing something, and
some activities are bad ones.
Like if you actually do running
instruction, that's good.
If your running is useful
instruction, a long
time, you're OK.
But you might doing actually
[UNINTELLIGIBLE],
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[? misprediction ?], stuff like
that, that's bad activity.
You [UNINTELLIGIBLE] say, aha.
I am spending a lot of time
doing something that I can
avoid, and how do
I avoid that?
So that's what you
want to look at.
And you have two ways of doing
that, and I want to give you
an analogy to figure
out what it is.
So assume you are going,
visiting a bunch
of different places.
You're on a city tour.
You are visiting different
parts of the city.
And I want to figure out,
where do you spend
most of your time?
And that's a hard problem,
because I am sitting in my
office, and say, OK, you're
going [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the city.
I want to figure out where you
spend most of the time.
I have two ways of doing that.
I'm a busy person.
What I can do is every 30
minutes, I can call you and
say, where are you?
And you say, OK, I'm in this
library, I'm in this--
and then at that point, I can
have a histogram and say, he's
still in the library.
And I can call again,
where are you?
And I can log that.
And at some point, at the end
of the day, I'll have a
histogram saying, every time I
call, you found something.
If you spend a lot of time in
the science museum, I will
have a bunch of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
We'll see [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
become then, and if you are not
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], if you
have only one [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
find out, OK, you're not
spending time there.
That's one way to do that.
Let's go [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
saying, for every landmark, I
create a telephone booth.
And every time you enter a
landmark, you [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the telephone booth, you've got
to call an operator and
say what time it is, so
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And then you call me and say,
aha, I'm entering this
landmark, the time now is 5:50,
and I write it down.
And every time you exit the
landmark, you call me and say,
I'm exiting this landmark.
Time now is--
I write it down.
OK?
These are kind of two
ways of doing that.
That's like an instrumentation
solution.
So the sampling collector-based
periodically
interupt the processor and look
at where you are, and
depending on where you are,
you can mark that off.
And it's called time-based
sampling means every time,
every 100 milliseconds or
something, in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
processing, you stop and
say where you are.
Event-based sampling means you
are counting number of events
like cache meters.
Every hundred cache meters, you
stop and say, OK, where
has this happened?
Of course, if the cache misses
happen in a regular pattern,
you might be in trouble, because
every hundred, you
might be the same place, then
you would get a skewed number.
But most probably, there's
a statistical
variation in there.
You can get [? account index ?]
and figure out where these
things happen.
So if you're looking at where
all the cache [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is happening, you don't look at
every miss, because there
are millions of miss.
Every 10,000 miss, you figure
out where you are, and
statistically, one is missing
many times, that will adapt in
that column.
And nice thing about
that is, there's
nothing you need to do.
Now installation, no changes to
application you need to do.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] here, you know
how to go in changes,
phone booth everywhere.
Wide coverage.
You can cover everything.
So that means, assume you
install phone booth in all the
fixed landmarks, but there's a
service [UNINTELLIGIBLE] down.
I didn't see.
I don't have a phone
booth there.
But here, if I'm calling you,
I know I'm [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you, anyplace you are, I will
cover, even though I haven't
anticipated that point.
Very low overhead, because I can
decide to call you every
30 minutes or call you every 1
minute, if I really care or
worry about you, and I can
control the overhead that I'm
looking at, basically.
The problem is its approximate
position.
Because if you spend 5 hours
at MIT and 30 seconds at
Harvard, I will never know
that you went to Harvard,
because I might have not called
you while you were
there at Harvard.
You might think it's boring
and come back, and I never
knew that you did that.
And also, the other thing is, I
don't know exactly how many
times you went to a place,
because I might have called
you 10 times, and I found you
in the museum of the science
10 times, but you might have
gone there 20 times, and I
might have missed you under the
times I didn't call, or
you might have gone there only
five times and stayed for a
long time, and I might have
called multiple times.
I don't know that, and I don't
know the count of times you
are gone, which is
hard to know.
So the main thing is there might
be things that are not
that statistically significant
that you might miss.
And if you care about that,
it's not a good bet.
But most of the time we care
about the really statistically
significant things, so this
is a really good method.
The other part is perfect
accuracy, because every time
you go somewhere, you have to
call me, and I know how many
times you went to the
museum of science.
I know exactly the time
you enter and exited a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I know all of those things
[INAUDIBLE].
The problem of that is kind
of low granularity.
I can't put phone booth at every
corner, and if you had
called me at every corner,
it's going
to be way too expensive.
So I have low granularity, very
good information, and
also high overhead.
Because if you're going in and
out a lot to a building, you
have to call, you have
to stop and call,
it's very high overhead.
And there's not much of a way
for me to control that.
And it's also high touch.
That means I have to build all
that infrastructure, I have to
go and modify your application,
basically, in
something [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
compile time application, get
modified to basically have all
these [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
installed into the
application.
So you can look a lot of
different types of events.
So in Intel, if you look at
core performance counters,
there are hundreds of
performance counters.
And some of these performance
counters have no sense
whatsoever.
So for example, Intel has
this counter called
number of bogus branches.
What's a bogus branch?
I mean, why should Intel be
doing anything bogus?
It's some [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
came out.
But there are some counters
that are useful, so you're
sort of getting [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
by thousands of things
available, we focus on things
that we care about.
Things like branch events,
load store events, cache
meter, prefetchers.
Those are the important things,
and some multicore
events that we can look at,
and get some interesting
information.
And a lot of times, just by
looking at numbers doesn't
make too much sense.
You know you had $5 billion,
$300 million branches missed.
Is it a good high or low?
You have no idea.
The right thing is, OK.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to number of instruction
executed how much it would be.
The most important numbers
are ratios.
So from the branches executed,
how many were missed?
That's a lot more important
than, you have 5 billion
branch misses.
That doesn't say
anything to me.
So most of the time, you have
to figure out the right
ratios, and what makes sense
to look at those ratios.
So now what I want to do is
to go through a couple of
examples and show what
I can see in these
different program behaviors.
Any questions so far?
Next lecture we are going to go
through hands-on examples,
going through some of these
profiling tools.
So it's kind of fun--
what I did was finally discover
what architecture is
doing, and what is the modern
multicore is capable of doing.
In fact, some of these examples,
so this set of
examples were done
on a Core Two.
So some of the numbers might
be very different in
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], because the
architecture might do better
in some special prediction
stuff.
I don't know.
It might be fun to
move it it again.
So what I have is a program
that I first created two
interesting arrays to
access this array.
One array has numbers 1 to n,
MAXA, is stored in this array.
This has 1 to MAXA in random
order stored in this array.
So when I use this as a way to
access the main array, and if
I use this in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
0 to n, I will actually access
A [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
0.
It's almost like saying AI.
But I use this here.
But if I use this one, I'm doing
random [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Well, the first program I'm
doing is just nothing but
going through this one.
I will have autoloop that will
go through many, many times,
so I can actually
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
time.
So I just go through--
just nothing but trying to
just go through that.
Second thing I did, I just
put a condition.
Say, j is than MAXA half.
That means halfway through
the program, I will go
and update this one.
Another half, I'm not
doing anything.
Then I said, OK, look.
I divide by every fourth
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So what I is j and
with 03 in there.
That means 3 means [? 2b ?]
in the 1 1.
So we study 0.
That means last two
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] has to be 0.
To form in delta every fourth
element, I will update.
Otherwise I won't.
And the next thing I
did was I updated--
OK.
Let me ask you a question.
So this program, the output--
that means what happened
to A--
the output of A is equivalent to
some other program, one of
these three programs.
Which one is the [? outward ?]
equivalent?
See what you can make up.
So first three programs or
each will have separate
different outputs.
A at A would be different
if you run it.
Except the fourth program will
produce the exact same results
as some other program, on the
first three programs.
Which one?
Wake up, wake up, wake up!
I hear something.
I hear some--
second one.
Somebody said the second one.
How many people agree
with that?
How many people disagree?
OK.
This is not a statistical
example.
It can be exact.
Why say the second one?
Second one is right.
So what that means is, in fact,
instead of a j, I'm
using inc j.
Inc j is exactly j, because it
goes, inc 0 is 0, inc 1 is 1,
inc 2 is 2.
I just created the same
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
array in here.
This is something to get that.
And finally, I am doing
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
A basically from x.
So what that means, I'm using
the same amount of data will
get updated, but it's very
different order in there.
So now, before I go to
the next slide--
question?
AUDIENCE: Maybe you said this,
but what is the A array?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Yeah,
it's some numbers.
Some random set of numbers.
I don't care about that.
I just updated this one.
So in here, which program do
we think run the faster?
So let me ask you this--
which program updated the least
amount of updates for A?
Third one, yeah, because
it's only doing
every fourth element.
Which did the most?
First one is doing every
element, and everybody else
will do probably half
of the updates.
So knowing that, which program
will run faster?
First one is updating
everything.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], OK.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
plus 1, OK.
Which program will run slow?
Last one.
You guys are onto something.
You have seen my slide, you
actually know what the
hell is going on.
So what I show here is, you
can't read this one, but I
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
on time, and then I
create a ratio.
So if you look at the ratio--
so aha.
The first program, I always
normalize to that, runs 1, and
that runs the fastest, if you
tried, and the last program
ran the slowest.
And the interesting thing is,
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE], the
other, the two, the second and
fourth one, that wrote about
half [UNINTELLIGIBLE], basically
ran all of the same.
But the one that wrote every
fourth element was actually
slower than others.
Why is it going on?
So what you can do is, first
look at how many instructions
would it add up, and how many
instruction were executed?
So if you look at that, what
you see is, the first one
executes the least amount of
instructions, because it
doesn't have to do all
this [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
when it's updating.
The interesting thing is, the
one that wrote half has the
most amount of instructions.
One that wrote only 1/4 has
middle amount of instructions.
That kind of makes
sense in here.
But this still doesn't
explain the slowdown.
That means if this is the only
case, the divide by 4 should
run faster than the
other three.
That doesn't make sense.
And then what you look at,
look at [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
branches in there, and if you
look at the branches,
what you see is--
Let me skip this
one, actually.
I want to get this one.
This is called clocks
per instruction.
What this is is, if the
instructions ran slow, these
instructions will take a
lot more clock cycles.
That means the instructions
are not doing well.
That means they are
stalling, they are
taking a lot more time.
Normally, we should be able
to run [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
about four instruction
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] cycles should
get a CPA of 0.25, but that's
very rare, and if you look at
that, if I normalize, I get
1 in here normalized.
And then what you see is second
and fourth test, almost
the same CPI, and the third has
worse, and the last one is
even worse.
So why is that?
Why are those instructions
doing bad?
And then you can go look
at that misprediction
instruction, and this is
exactly what happens.
Divide by 4.
This is a condition.
The branch predictor couldn't
predict it that well, because
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
predicted in the first three,
and it's [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
predicted, OK, after three,
next one is also going 1
direction, oops, it's in
another direction.
OK, going first three
predictions, going one
direction, knowing
that information.
So divide by 4, looks really
bad, then predict 3.
And then the random one was
just completely off.
Random one, basically
predictions of three
[INAUDIBLE].
That's why this is.
So in fact, if you just want to
calculate the run time, if
you think every misprediction
cost you 21 instructions, you
kind of get the exact
total first.
You can't help it.
So after you meet the
instruction, take one cycle,
and everybody misprediction
instruction, take 21 cycles,
and you just calculate that.
And this [UNINTELLIGIBLE], I
just came, took it out of a
hat, and then voila, I get
a number that's very
close to run time.
So what that means is, I can
kind of understand what the
behavior, this explains
what's going on.
So I can have a model in my
head for what's going on.
So it's all about misprediction
in here.
I did two other experiments
I have the slide sitting here,
but I don't think I have too
much time to go.
I want to go to the
numbers in there.
Are you ready, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
OK.
Why don't you go put
your laptop in.
You have the dongle?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK.
So voila.
So something you guys waited all
this time, and were up all
these days developing.
So let's see how
everybody did.
OK, without further ado.
I haven't even seen
these numbers.
OK, what happened?
He's trying to--
OK, good.
This is [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
screen, OK.
Do you have it?
OK.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Something to keep in mind
is, we haven't actually
investigated what's causing
people to have build failures
or crashes yet.
So it could be your fault,
it could be ours.
We'll figure that out.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So if
smaller, better or higher,
better, what's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] better.
This is run time.
That
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: This
is really good!
This is actually--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
The baseline is the flat code
that you see in the middle.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So
this is really good.
That means there were
kind of two groups.
Most of the people got
everything right, and they're
now the bottom.
And there's another group that
missed something, and it's in
the second camp.
AUDIENCE: I think some of these
projects are from people
who dropped the class
at some point.
So there's probably
[INAUDIBLE]
might not be actually
representative of the class.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So last
year, we got like almost
exponential curve, actually.
Last year, what happened was
there were a couple of people
at the bottom, and everybody
worked at the top, basically.
Which is actually good.
So you guys actually figured
out what's going on.
AUDIENCE: So next one is
even more interesting.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Wow!
AUDIENCE: So this
is [INAUDIBLE]
that we gave you guys.
Most of you optimized it
down to 0 seconds.
So I coded in a harder
test case, and here's
the results on that.
Still pretty good.
[INAUDIBLE]
There's some very specific
optimizations [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So exactly.
There are people who are
climbing up, I don't know
exactly what, but it's very
clear that [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
probably data representation
tag that
people missed in here.
Which is really now
interesting.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: And for Pentominos,
this is very incomplete,
because the set of tests that
we wanted to run are still
currently running.
So I just picked a random test
case, just to give everybody
an idea of how everybody did,
and set the time out very low
so that I could actually finish
it during this lecture.
And what's [INAUDIBLE]?
Yes.
Somebody solved it
instantaneously, and it
searches for the first 5,000
solutions to some random
puzzle that I pulled out.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: That I haven't
verified yet.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Aha.
So it might be, there might be
just the scratchings, so we
don't know that, and then that
could be correct answer, but--
AUDIENCE: Which one
is the baseline?
The baseline is actually
the 90-second mark.
[INAUDIBLE]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the baseline?
AUDIENCE: No.
10 seconds and above are either
timeout or [INAUDIBLE].
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Oh, they're
probably mostly timeouts.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Yes.
So there you are.
This one, people would have some
work to do, I guess, to
get the performance down.
But this is pretty good.
This is not like
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I mean, last couple of
years, we had people,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
someone who was 1,000
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], you had to
plot it in a log thing.
So in fact, if I do a square
root within the grid, this is
pretty nice.
So [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is not that bad.
So this is great.
This is where you get
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
performance wise And if you are
in the bottom, you can go
have a beer.
Otherwise, you might have to
go back and figure out what
you missed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Oh, if
you're [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Yes, exactly yes.
I should say that.